so maybe this is a good chance to step
back you mentioned open to point oh
but go back to open cargo 10.9 yeah yeah
maybe talk to the history and you're
thinking about ends ideas I would say
OpenCog 2.0 is a term we're throwing
around sort of tongue-in-cheek because
the existing open cog system that we're
working on now is not remotely close to
what we considered we'd consider one a
1.0 right I'm in the eminence
it's an early it's been around what 13
years or something but it's still an
early stage research system right and
actually where we are going back to the
beginning in terms of theory and
implementation because we feel like
that's the right thing to do but I'm
sure what we end up with is gonna have a
huge amount in common with with the
current system I mean we all still like
that the general approach so there's a
first of all what is OpenCog sure
OpenCog is an open source software
project that I launched together with
several others in 2008 and probably the
first code written toward that was
written in 2001 or 2 or something that
was developed as a proprietary code base
within my a our company novo meant a LLC
then we decided to open source it into
in 2008 cleaned up the code throughout
some things I had added some new things
and well languages it written in C++
primarily there's a bunch of scheme as
well but most of it and it's separate
from that something we'll also talk
about a singularity net so yeah yeah
it's born as a non networked thing
correct correct
well there are many levels of networks
and involved here but connectivity to
the Internet Oh No Oh at birth
yeah I mean singularity net is a
separate project and a separate body of
code and you can use singularity net as
part of the infrastructure for a
distributed OpenCog system that they are
there there are different layers yeah so
OpenCog on the one hand as a software
framework could be used to implement a
variety of different AI architectures
and and algorithms but in practice
there's been a group of developers which
I've been leading together with leanness
Webster snow guys father and a few
others which have been using the OpenCog
platform and infrastructure to to
implement certain ideas about how to
make an AGI so that there's been a
little bit of ambiguity about OpenCog
the software platform versus OpenCog the
the AGI design because in theory you
could use that software to do you could
use it to make a neural net you could
you could use it to make a lot of
difference what kind of stuff does the
software platform provide so terms to
utilities feels like what what yeah let
me first tell about OpenCog as a
software platform and then I'll tell you
the specific AGI Rd we've been building
building on top of it yep so the core
component of OpenCog is a software
platform is what we call the atom space
which is a weighted labeled hypergraph
8000m atoms bottom space yeah and not
not atom like either in the yeah so you
have a hyper graph which is like so a
graph in this sense is a bunch of nodes
with links between them a hyper graph is
like a graph but links can go between
more than two nodes so you have a link
between three nodes and in fact in fact
open calls atom space would properly be
called a meta graph because you can have
links pointing to links or you could
have links pulling the whole sub graphs
right so it's a it's an extended hyper
graph or a meta graph and there's my
graph a technical term it is now a
technical term interesting but well I
don't think it was yet a technical term
when we started calling this a
generalized hyper graph in but in in any
case it's a way of labelled generalized
hyper graph for what
labeled metagraph the the weights and
labels mean that the nodes and links can
have numbers and symbols attached to
them so they can have types on them they
can have numbers on that represent say a
truth value or an importance value for
it for a certain purpose and of course
like with all things you can reduce that
to a hyper graph than the hyper graph to
a graph and you could use the graph to
an adjacency matrix so I mean there's
always multiple representation there's a
way of representation as ya walk well
here and so similarly you could have a
link to a whole graph because a whole
graph could represent say a body of
information and I could say I reject
this body of information then one way to
do that is make that link go to that
whole sub graph representing the body of
information right I mean there's many
there are many alternate representations
but that's anyway what we have in
OpenCog we have an atom space which is
this weighted label generalized hyper
graph knowledge store it lives in RAM
there's also a way to back it up to disk
there are ways to spread it among among
multiple different machines then there
are various utilities for dealing with
that so there's a pattern matcher which
lets you specify a sort of abstract
pattern and then search through a whole
atom space with labeled hypergraph to
see what sub hypergraphs may match that
that pattern for an example so that's
then there's there's something called
the the COG server in OpenCog which lets
you run a bunch of different agents or
processes in a scheduler and each of
these agents basically it reads stuff
from the atom space and it writes stuff
to the atom space so that this is sort
of the basic operational model yes the
software framework right and and of
course that's there's a lot there just
from a scalable software engineering
standpoint so you can use this I don't
know if you've have you looked into the
Stephen Wolfram physics project recently
with the hypo grassless though
theoretically used like the software
framework to be certainly could although
Wolfram would rather die than use
anything but Mathematica for his work
well--that's yeah but there's a big
community of people who are you know
would love integration I like that you
said the young minds love the idea of
integrating of connect that's right and
I would add on that note the idea of
using hypergraph type models in physics
is not very new like if if you look at
the Russians did it first well I'm sure
they did and a gun and then drivers
who's a mathematician a professor in
Louisiana or somewhere had to be
beautiful book on quantum sets and
hypergraphs and algebraic topology for
discrete models of physics and carried
it much farther than than more from
house but he's he's not rich and famous
so so it didn't didn't get in the
headlines but yeah Wolfram aside yes
certainly that's a good way to put it
the whole OpenCog framework you could
use it to model biological networks and
then simulate biology processes you
could use it to model physics on
discrete graph models of physics seem
like you could use it you could use it
to do say biologically realistic neural
networks for example and that's so that
that's a framework what do a gent some
processes do do they grow the graph
today what kind of computations just to
get get a sense so this so they in
theory they could do anything they want
to do they're just C++ processes on the
other hand the computation framework is
sort of designed for agents where most
of their processing time is taken up
with reads and writes to the atom space
and so that's that's a very different
processing model than say the matrix
multiplication based model as underlies
most deep most deep learning systems
right so so you could I mean you could
create an agent that just factored
numbers for a billion years it would run
within the OpenCog platform but it would
be pointless right I mean the point of
doing OpenCog is because you want to
make agents that are cooperating via
reading and writing it into this this
weighted labelled hyper graph right and
so that and that that has both cognitive
architecture importance the
then this hypergraph is being used as a
sort of shared memory among different
cognitive processes but it also has in
the software and hardware implementation
implications because current GPU
architectures are not so useful for
OpenCog whereas a graph chip would be
incredibly useful right and I think
graph core has those now but they're not
ideally suited for this but I think in
the next let's say three to five years
we're gonna see new chips where like a
graph is put on the chip and and you
know the back and forth between multiple
processes acting Cindy and Mindy on that
on that graph is going to be fast and
then that may do for OpenCog type
architectures what GPUs did for for deep
neural architecture it's a small tangent
can you comment on thoughts about
neuromorphic computing so like hardware
implementations of all these different
kind of I mean are you interested
are you excited by that bus I mean I'm
excited by graph processors because I
think they can massively speed up speed
up OpenCog which is the class of
architectures that I'm that I'm working
on I think if you know in principle
neuromorphic computing should be amazing
I haven't yet been fully sold on any of
the systems that are out there like
memristors should be amazing too right
so a lot of these things have obvious
potential but I can't yet put my hands
on the system that that seemed a matter
fact that Marxism should be amazing but
the current systems yeah not be for
example if you wanted to make a
biologically realistic Hardware neural
network like taking making a circuit in
hardware that emulated like the
hodgkin-huxley equation or the issue
keverage equation like equate
differential equations for biologically
realistic neuron and putting that in
hardware on the chip that would seem
that would make more feasible to make a
large-scale truly biologically realistic
neural network know what's been done so
far is not like that so I guess
personally as a researcher I mean I've
done a bunch of work in cognitive
neuroscience a tional neuroscience where
I did some work with IR pas in in in DC
intelligence Advanced Research Project
agency we were looking at how do you how
do you make a biologically realistic
simulation of seven different parts of
the brain cooperating with each other
using like realistic nonlinear dynamical
models of neurons and how do you get
that to simulate what's going on in the
mind of a GEOINT intelligence analyst
while they're trying to find terrorists
on a map right so if you want to do
something like that
having neuromorphic hardware that really
let you simulate like a realistic model
of the neuron would would be it would be
amazing but that's that's started with
my computational neuroscience and
alright with an AGI hat on
I'm just more interested in these
hypergraph knowledge representation
based architectures which would benefit
benefit more from from various types of
graph processors because the main
processing bottleneck is reading writing
to ram it's reading writing to the graph
in RAM the main processing bottleneck
for this kind of kernel IGI architecture
is not multiplying matrices and and for
that reason GPUs which are really good
at multiplying matrices don't apply as
as well there there are frameworks like
gunrock and others that try to boil down
graph processing to matrix operations
and then they're cool but you're still
putting a square peg into a round hole
in a certain one the same is true I mean
current quantum machine learning which
is very cool it's also all about how to
get matrix and vector operations in
quantum mechanics and I see why that's
natural to do I mean quantum mechanics
is all unitary matrices and vectors what
on the other hand you could also try to
make graph centric quantum computers
which i think is is is where things will
go and then then we can have then we can
make like take the OpenCog
implementation layer implement it in a
uncollapse state inside the quantum
computer but that that may be the
singularity squared right I'm not I'm
not I'm not sure we need that too
get the human human love killer that's
already beyond the the first thing Glade
but can we go back to open car no no Bo
and the hypergraph and oh yeah that's
the software framework right so then the
next thing is our cognitive architecture
tells us particular algorithms to put
there got it can we backtrack on the
kind of do is this graph designed is it
in general supposed to be sparse and the
operations constantly grow and change
the graph is sparse and but is it
constantly adding links it's always a
self modifying hyper graph so it's not
so the write and read operations you
were referring to this isn't just a
fixed graph to which you change the way
it's a growing graph yeah that yeah that
that's that's true so it's it is
different model then say current deep
neural Nets and have a fixed neural
architecture and you're updating the
weights although there have been like
cascade correlational neural
architectures that grow new new nodes
and links but the most common neural
architecture is now have a fixed neural
architecture you're updating the weights
and then OpenCog you can update the
weights and that certainly happens a lot
but adding new nodes adding new links
removing nodes and links is an equally
critical part of the system's operations
yeah so now when you start to add these
cognitive algorithms on top of this
OpenCog architecture what does that look
like
so what yes so that within this
framework then creating a cognitive
architecture is basically two things
it's it's choosing what type system you
want to put on the nodes and links in
the hyper graph what types of nodes and
links you want and then then it's
choosing what collection of agents what
collection of AI algorithms or processes
are going to run to operate on this
hyper graph and of course those two
decisions arkla are closely closely
connected to each other so in terms of
the type system there are some links
that are more neural net like they're
just like have weights to get updated by
heavy and learning
and activation spreads among them there
are other links that are more logic like
and noted in more logic like so you
could have a variable node and eat you
can have a node representing a universal
or existential quantifier as in in
predicate logic or term logic so you can
have logic like nodes and links or you
can have neural like nodes and links you
can also have procedure like nodes and
links as in say combinatorial logic or
lambda calculus representing programs so
you can have nodes and links
representing many different types of
semantics which means you can make a
horrible ugly mess or you can make a
system where these different types of
knowledge all interpenetrate and
synergize with each other beautifully
right so you so the hypo graph can't
contain programs yet can contain
programs although it can in the current
version it is a very inefficient way to
guide the execution of programs which is
one thing that we are aiming to resolve
with our rewrite of the system now so
what to you is the most beautiful
aspects of OpenCog just you personally
some aspect that captivates your
imagination from beauty or power what
what fascinates me is finding a common
representation that underlies abstract
declarative knowledge and sensory
knowledge and movement knowledge and
procedural knowledge and episodic
knowledge finding the right level of
representation where all these types of
knowledge are stored in a sort of
universal and interconvertible yet
practically manipulable way right so
that's to me to me that's the core
because once you've done that then the
different learning algorithms can help
each other out like what you want is if
you have a logic engine that helps with
declarative knowledge and you have a
deep neural net the gathers perceptual
knowledge and you have say an
evolutionary learning system that learns
procedures
you want these to not only interact on
the level of sharing results and passing
inputs and outputs to each other you
want the logic engine when they get
stuck to be able to share its
intermediate state with the neural net
and with the evolutionary learning
algorithm so that they can help each
other out of bottlenecks and help each
other solve combinatorial explosions by
intervening inside each other's
cognitive processes but that can only be
done if the intermediate state of a
logic engine the evolutionary learning
engine and the deep neural net are
represented in the same form and that's
what we figured out how to do by putting
the right type system on top of this
weighted labeled hyper graph so is there
can you maybe elaborate I want that what
are the different characteristics of a
type system that that can coexist
amongst all these different kinds of
knowledge that needs to be represented
and this I mean like is it harka Cole
just any kind of insights you can give
on that ya know types oh yeah yes so
this this this gets very nitty-gritty
and and mathematical of course but what
one key part is switching from predicate
logic to term logic what is predicate
logic what is term logic so term logic
was invented by Aristotle or at least
that's though the oldest oldest
recollection we we have we have of it
but term logic breaks down basic logic
into basically simple links between
nodes like an inheritance link between
between node a and and node B so in term
logic the basic deduction operation is a
implies B B implies C therefore a
implies C whereas in predicate logic the
basic operation is modus ponens like a a
a a implies B therefore B so there
there's slightly different way of
breaking down logic but by breaking down
logic into term logic you get a nice way
of breaking logic down into into into
nodes and links so your concepts come
come become nodes the logical relations
become links and so then inference is
like so if this link is a implies B this
link is B implies
than deduction builds on like a implies
C and the and your probabilistic
algorithm can assign assign a certain
weight there now you may also have like
a heavy in neural link from A to C which
is the degree to which thinking the
degree to which a being the focus of
attention should make me the focus of
attention right so you could have done a
neuro-link and and you could you could
have a symbolic like logical inheritance
link in your term logic and they have
separate meaning but they they could be
used to guide each other as well like if
if there is a large amount of neural
weight on the link between a and B that
may direct your logic engine to think
about what is the relation are they
similar is is there an inheritance
relation are they sent are they similar
in some context on the other hand if
there's a logical relation between a and
B that may want that made you write your
neural component to think what when I'm
thinking about a book should I be
directing some attention to B also
because there's a logical relation so in
terms of logic there's a lot of thought
that went into how do you break down
logic relations including basic sort of
propositional logic relations as eros
fulfilling in term logic deals with and
then quantifier logic relations also how
do you break those down elegantly into a
hyper graph because you I mean you can
boil a logic expression into a graph in
many different ways many of them are
very ugly right we tried to find elegant
ways of sort of hierarchically breaking
down complex logic expression into note
into nodes and links so that if you have
say different nodes representing you
know been a I'll X interview or whatever
the logic relations between those things
are compact in the in the northern link
representation so that when you have a
neuron that acting on those same nodes
and links the neural net and the logic
engine can can sort of inter
interoperate with each other and also
interpret over by humans is that is that
an important stuff yeah in simple cases
it's interpreted by humans but honestly
you know
I would say logic systems give more
potential for yeah transparency and
comprehensibility then neural net
systems but you still have to work at it
because I mean if if I show you a
predicate logic proposition with like
500 nested Universal and existential
quantifiers and 217 variables that's no
more comprehensible than the weight
metrics of a neural network right so
that I'd say the logic expressions and
AI learns from its experience are mostly
totally opaque to human beings and may
be even harder to understand than that
because I mean when you have multiple
nested quantifier bindings it's a very
high level of abstraction there is a
difference though in the within logic
it's a little more straightforward to
pose the problem of like normalize this
and boil this down to a certain form I
mean you can do that in neural nets too
like you can distill a neural net to a
simpler form but that's more often done
to make a neural net that'll run on an
embedded device or something it's it's
harder to distill a net to a
comprehensible form then is to simplify
logic expression to a comprehensible
form but but it doesn't come for free
like what's what's in the a eyes mind is
is incomprehensible to to a human unless
you do some special work to make it
comprehensible so on the on the
procedural side there's some different
than sort of interesting
voodoo there I mean if it if you're
familiar in computer science there's
something called the Curie Howard
correspondence which is a one-to-one
mapping between proofs and programs so
every program can be mapped into a proof
every proof can be mapped into a program
you can model this using category theory
and about a bunch of a bunch of nice
math but we want to make that practical
alright so that so that if you if you
have an executive or program that like
moves the robots arm or figures out in
what order to say things in a dialogue
that's a procedure representing it in
open cogs hypergraph but if you want a
reason on how the how that improve that
procedure you need to map that procedure
into logic using curry Howard
isomorphism so then the logic the logic
engine can reason about how to improve
that procedure and then map that back
into the procedural represent
that is efficient for execution so again
that comes down to not just can you make
your procedure into a bunch of nodes and
links because I mean that can be done
trivially as a C++ compiler has nodes
and links inside it can you boil down
your procedure into a bunch of nodes and
links in a way that's like
hierarchically decomposed and simple
enough you can reason them yeah yeah
that given the resource constraints at
hand you can map it back and forth to
your to your term logic like fast enough
and without having a bloated logic
expression all right so there's just a
lot of there's a lot of nitty-gritty
particulars there but by the same token
if you if you ask a chip designer like
how do you make the Intel i7 chips so
good there's a there's a long list of
technical answers there which we'll take
take awhile to go through right and this
has been decades of work I'm in the the
first AI system of this nature I tried
to build what's called web mine in the
mid 1990s and we had a big graph a big
graph operating in RAM implemented with
Java 1.1 which is a terrible terrible
implementation idea and then each each
node has its own processing so like that
they're the core loop loop through all
nodes in the network and then he's node
in act with its little thing was doing
and we had logic and neural nets in
there but an evolutionary learning but
we hadn't done enough of the math to get
them to operate together very cleanly so
it was really it was quite a horrible
mess so as as well as shift doing an
implementation where the graph is its
own object and the agents are separately
scheduled we've also done a lot of work
on how do you represent programs how you
represent procedures you know how do you
represent genotypes for evolution in a
way that the interoperability between
the different types of learning
associated with these different types of
knowledge that actually works and that's
been quite difficult it's taken decades
and it's totally off to the side of what
the commercial mainstream of the of the
aiai field is doing which isn't thinking
about representation
at all really although you can see like
in the DNC they had to think a little
bit about how do you make representation
of a map and this memory matrix work
together with a representation needed
for a visual pattern recognition in the
hierarchical neural network but I would
say what we have taken that direction of
taking the types of knowledge you need
for different types of learning like
declarative procedural attentional and
how do you make these types of knowledge
represent in a way that allows cross
learning across these different types of
memory
we've been prototyping and experimenting
with this within OpenCog and before that
web mind since the mid mid 1990s
now disappointingly to all of us this
has not yet been cashed out in and they
in an AGI system right I mean we've used
this system within our consulting
business so we've built natural language
processing and robot control and
financial analysis we built a bunch of
sort of vertical market specific
proprietary AI projects they used
OpenCog on the backend but we haven't
that's not the AGI goal right that's
it's interesting but it's not the AGI
goal so now what what we're looking at
with our rebuild at the system to point
out yeah we're also calling it true AGI
so we're not quite sure what the name it
with the name is yeah that we we made a
website for - AGI die oh but we haven't
put anything on there yet we may come up
with an even better in the input it's
kind of like the real AI 19.4 URI yeah
what I'd like true better because true
has like you can be true hearted right
you can be true to your girlfriend so
true true that true has to has a number
and they also has logic in it right
because logic is I like it yeah so yeah
with the with the true AGI system we're
sticking with the same basic
architecture but where we're trying to
build on what we've learned and what one
thing we've learned is that you know we
need type checking among dependent types
to be much faster and among
probabilistic dependent types to be much
so as it is now you can have complex
types on the nodes and links but if you
want to put like if you want types to be
first-class citizens so that you can
have the types can be variables and and
then you do type checking among complex
higher-order types you can do that in
the system now but it's very slow this
is stuff like it's done in in cutting
edge programming languages like like
Agda or something these obscure research
languages on the other hand we've been
doing a lot time together deep neural
nets with symbolic learning so we did a
project for Cisco for example which was
on this was street scene analysis but
they had deep neural models for a bunch
of cameras watching street scenes but
they trained a different model for each
camera because they couldn't get the
transfer learning to work between camera
a and camera B so we took what came out
of all the deep neural models for the
different cameras we fed it into an open
called symbolic representation then we
did some pattern mining and some
reasoning on what came out of all the
different cameras within the symbolic
graph and that worked well for that
application I mean you go lotta P from
Cisco gave a talk touching on that at
last year's ad hoc conference it was in
Shenzhen
on the other hand we learned from there
it was kind of clunky to get the deep
neural models to work well with the
symbolic system because we were using
torch and torch keeps a sort of state
computation graph but you needed like
real-time access to that computation
graph within our hyper graph and that
what we certainly did it Aleksei parla
path leads our st. Petersburg team wrote
a great paper on cognitive modules in
OpenCog explaining sort of how do you
deal with the torch compute graph inside
OpenCog but in the end we realized like
that just hadn't been one of our design
thoughts when we when we built open
Congress so between wanting really fast
dependent type checking and wanting much
more efficient in their operation
between the computation graphs of deep
neural net frameworks and OpenCog cipher
graph and adding on top of that wanting
to more effectively run an open-cockpit
graph distributed across the RAM in
10,000 machines which is we're doing
dozens of machines now but it's just not
we we didn't architect it with that sort
of modern scalability in mind so
these performance requirements who would
have driven us to want to reorder TechEd
the the base but the core AGI paradigm
doesn't really change like like the
mathematics is is the same it's just we
can't scale to the level that we want in
terms of distributed processing or speed
of various kinds of processing with the
current infrastructure that was you know
built in the face 2001 to 2008 which is
which is hard is hardly shocking right
well I mean the three things you
mentioned are really interesting so what
do you think about in terms of inter
probability communicating with
computational graph of neural networks
what do you think about the
representations that neural networks
form I'm they're bad but there's many
ways that you could that you could deal
with that so I've been wrestling with
this a lot in some work on unsupervised
grammar induction and I have a simple
paper on that that I'll give it the next
a gagi conference the online portion of
which is next week actually what is
grammar induction so this isn't AGI
either but it's sort of on the verge
between narrow AI and AGI or something
unsupervised grammar induction is the
problem
throw your AI system a huge body of text
and have it turn the grammar of the
language that produced that text so
you're not giving it labeled examples so
you're not giving it like a thousand
sentence is what the parsers were marked
up by graduate students so it's just got
to infer the grammar from from from the
text it's like it's like the rosetta
stone but worse right because you only
have the one language yeah and you have
to figure out what what is the grammar
so that's not really
AGI because I mean the way a human
learns language is not that right I mean
we learned from language that's used in
context so it's a social embodied thing
we see we see how a given sense is
grounded in in observation there's an
interactive element I guess yeah yeah
yeah on the other hand and so I'm more
interested in that I'm more interested
in making an AGI system learn language
from its social and embodied experience
on the other hand that's also more of a
pain
to do and that would lead us into Hanson
robotics and their robotics will have no
much talked about in a few minutes miss
but just as an intellectual exercise as
a learning exercise trying to learn
grammar from a corpus is very very
interesting right and and that's been a
field in AI for a long time no one can
do it very well
so we've been looking at transforming
neural networks and tree transformers
which are amazing these came out of
Google Google brain actually and
actually on that team was Lukas Kaiser
who used to work for me in in one the
period 2005 through 8 3 or something so
it's been fun to see my former sort of
AGI employees dispersed and do all these
amazing things with way too many sucked
into Google actually anyway we'll talk
about that yes Lucas Kaiser and a bunch
of these guys they create transformer
networks that classic paper like
attention is all you need and all these
things following on from that so we're
looking at transformer networks and like
these are able to I mean this is what
underlies GPT 2 and GPT 3 and so on
which are very very cool and have
absolutely no cognitive understanding of
any of the text or looking at like
they're they're very in tell they're
very intelligent idiots right no sorry
to take but it's a smaller bring us back
but do you think GPT 3 understands no no
you don't think GPT 20 will understand
no no no it's not gonna buy you any more
than the faster car is gonna get you the
most yeah ok it's a completely different
kind of thing I mean these networks are
very cool and as an entrepreneur I can
see many highly valuable uses for them
and as as an as an artist I love them
all right so I mean I we're using our
own neural model which is along those
lines to control the philip k dick robot
now and it's amazing to like train train
a neural model on the robot philip k
dick and see it come up with like crazy
stoned philosopher pronouncements very
much like what dick might have
said right
like that so these models are super cool
and I'm I'm working with Hanson robotics
now on using a similar but more
sophisticated one for Sophia which which
we have we haven't launched launch yet
but so I think it's cool but not-it's
not understand is it recognizing a large
number of shallow patterns they're not
they're not forming an abstract
representation and that's the point I
was coming to when we're looking at
grammar induction we tried to mine
patterns out of the structure the
transformer network and you can but the
patterns aren't what you want they're
they're nasty so I mean you if you do
supervised learning if you look at
sentences where you know the correct
parts of a sentence you can learn a
matrix the maps between the internal
representation of the transformer and
the parts of the sentence and so then
you can actually train something that
will output the sentence parse from the
transformer networks internal state and
we did this I think Christopher Manning
is some some others have not done this
also but I mean what you get is that the
representation is horribly ugly in the
scaring all over the network it doesn't
look like the rules of grammar that you
know are the right rules of grammar
right it's kind of ugly so what what
we're actually doing is we're using a
symbolic grammar learning algorithm but
we're using the terse formal neural
network as a sentence probability Oracle
so like when you if you have a rule of
grammar and you weren't sure if it's a
correct rule of grammar or not you can
generate a bunch of senses using that
rule of grammar and a bunch of senses
violating that rule of grammar and you
can see the the transformer model
doesn't think the senses are being the
rule of grammar are more probable than
the sense is disobeying the rule of
grammar so in that way you can use the
neural model as a sense probability
Oracle to guide guide a symbolic grammar
learning process and that's interesting
that seems to work better than trying to
milk they grammar out of the neural
network that doesn't have it in there so
I think the thing is these neural nets
are not getting a semantically
meaningful representation internally by
and large
so one line of research is to try to get
them to do that and in info gamma was
trying to do that so like if you look
back like two years ago there was all
these papers don't like ed Edward this
probabilistic programming neuron that
framework that Google had which came out
of info again something the idea there
was like you you could train an info
again neural net model which is a
generative associative network to
recognize and generate faces and the
model would automatically learn a
variable for how long the nose is and
automatically learn a variable for how
wide the eyes are or how big the lips
are or something right
so it automatically learned the these
variables which have a semantic meaning
so that that was a rare case where a
neural net trained with a fairly
standard Gann method was able to
actually learn the semantic
representation so for many years many of
us tried to take that the next step and
get again type neural network that that
would have not just a list of semantic
latent variables but we have to say a
Bayes net of semantic variables with
dependencies between them the whole
programming framework Edward was wasn't
was made for that I mean no one got to
work right and the cutting is possible
yeah I know I don't know it might be the
backpropagation just won't work for it
because the gradients are too screwed up
yeah maybe you could get to work using
CMAs or some like floating-point
evolutionary algorithm right we tried we
didn't get it to work eventually we just
paused that rather gave it up we pause
that and said well okay let's let's try
more innovative ways to learn implicit
to learn what are the representations
implicit in that network without trying
to make it grow inside that Network and
I described how we're doing that in
language you can do similar things in
vision right so what what is an Oracle
yeah yeah yeah so you can that's one way
is that you use a structure learning
algorithm which is symbolic and and then
you use the the deep neuron that as an
Oracle to guide the structure learning
algorithm the other way to do it is like
info again was trying to do and try to
tweak the neural network to have this
about representation inside it I I tend
to think what the brain is doing is more
like using the
deep neural net type thing as an Oracle
like I think the visual cortex or the
cerebellum are probably learning a non
semantically meaningful opaque tangled
representation and then when they
interface with the more cognitive parts
of the cortex the cortex is sort of
using those as an Oracle and learning
the abstract representation so if you do
sports saying take for example serving
in tennis right I mean my tennis serve
is okay not not great but I learned it
by trial and error right and I mean I
learned music by trial narrow to I just
sit down and play but then if you're an
athlete which I'm not a good athlete I
mean then you'll watch videos of
yourself
serving and your coach will help you
think about what you're doing and you'll
then form a declarative representation
but your cerebellum maybe didn't have a
declarative representation same way with
music like I will hear something in my
head I'll sit down and play the thing
like I heard it and then then I will try
to study what my fingers did to see like
what did you just play like I did you do
that right because if you're composing
you may want to see how you did it and
then declaratively morphed that in some
way that your fingers wouldn't wouldn't
think of right but the the physiological
movement may come out of some opaque
like cerebellar Ian foot reinforcement
learned thing right and so that's I
think trying to milk the structure of a
neuron that by treating as an Oracle may
be more like how your declarative mind
post processes what what your your
visual or or or motor cortex I mean I
mean in envision it's the same way like
you can recognize beautiful art much
better than you can say why you think
that piece of art is beautiful but if
you're trained as an art critic you do
learn to say why and some of it's
but some of it isn't right some of us
learning to map sensory knowledge into
declarative and and and linguist and
linguistic knowledge yet without
necessarily making the sensory system
itself views that use a transparent and
an easily communicable representation
yeah that's fascinating
to think of neural networks as like dumb
question answers that you can just milk
to build up a knowledge base and then
could be multiple networks I suppose
from different yeah yeah so I think if
if a group like deep mind they're open
they I were to build a a GI and I think
deep mind is like a thousand times more
likely from from from where I could tell
but because they have hired a lot of
people would broad minds and many
different approaches and angles are only
on the AG I was open AI is also awesome
but I see them as more of like a pure
deep reinforcement learning sauce time I
got a lot of you're right there's uh I
mean there's so much interdisciplinary
work at deep mind like gnocchi science
and you put that together with Google
brain the ground and they're not working
that closely together now but you know
my oldest son Zarathustra is doing his
PhD in machine learning applied to
automated theorem proving in Prague and
or Joseph urban so that the first paper
deep math which applied deep neural nets
to guide theorem proving without Google
brain I mean by now by now the the
automated theorem proving communities
going way way way beyond anything Google
was doing but still yeah that but anyway
if that community was gonna make an AGI
probably one way they would do it was
you know take twenty five different
neural modules architected in different
ways maybe resembling different parts of
the brain like a basil basil ganglia
model cerebellum aa thalam thalamus
small doing a few hip few hippocampus
models number of different models
representing parts of the cortex right
take all of these and then wire them
together to code train and learn them
together like that that would be an
approach to creating an AGI one could
implement something like that
efficiently on top of our are true AGI
like OpenCog 2.0 system once it exists
although obviously google has has their
own highly efficient implementation
architecture so I think that's a decent
way to build AGI I was very interested
in that in the midnight
but I mean the knowledge about how the
brain works sort of pissed me off like
it was it wasn't there like you know in
the hippocampus you have these concept
neurons like the so-called grandmother
neuron which everyone left and it's
actually they're like I have some Lex
Freedman neurons that fire
differentially when I see you and not
when I see any other person right yeah
so how do these Lex Freedman neurons how
do they coordinate with the distributed
representation of Lex Freedman I have in
my cortex right there's some back and
forth during cortex and hippocampus that
lets these discrete sub aaalac
representations in hippocampus correlate
and cooperate with the distributed
representations in cortex this probably
has to do with how the brain does its
version of abstraction and quantifier
logic right like you can have a single
neuron the hippocampus that activates
the whole distributed activation pattern
in cortex well this this may be how the
brain does like symbolization and
abstraction as in in functional
programming or something but we can't
measure it like we deliver enough
electrodes stuck between the the cortex
and the and the hippocampus in any known
experiment to measure it so I got I got
frustrated with that direction not
because it's impossible we just
understand enough yeah we don't of
course it's a valid research direction
you can try to understand more and more
and we aren't measuring more and more
about what what happens in the brain now
that than ever before so it's quite
interesting on the other hand I sort of
got more of an engineering mindset about
AGI and like well okay we don't know how
the brain works that well we don't know
how birds fly that well yet yeah either
we have no idea how a hummingbird flies
in terms of the aerodynamics of it on
the other hand we know basic principles
of like flapping and pushing the air
down and we know the basic principles of
how the different parts of the brain
work so let's take those basic
principles and engineer something that
embodies those base basic principles but
you know is well-designed for the
hardware that we have on hand right
right now do you think we can create a
GI before we understand it yeah I mean I
think I think that's probably that's
probably what will happen and
maybe the HEI will help us do better
brain imaging they will then let us
build artificial humans which is very
very interesting to us because we are
humans right I mean building artificial
humans is is super worthwhile I just
think it's probably not the shortest
path to AGI so it's fascinating idea
that we would build AGI to help us
understand ourselves you know a lot of
people ask me if you know the young
people interested in doing artificial
intelligence they look at sort of you
know doing graduate level even
undergrads but graduate level research
and they see the woods or the artificial
intelligence community stands now it's
not really AGI type research for the
most part yeah so the natural question
they ask is what advice would you give I
mean maybe I could ask if people were
interested in working on OpenCog or in
some kind of direct or indirect
connection to OpenCog or AGI research
what would you recommend OpenCog first
of all is open source project there's a
there's a Google Group this discussion
list there's a github repository so if
anyone's interested in lending hand with
that aspect of AGI introduce yourself
from the OpenCog email list and there's
a slack as well I mean we're we're
certainly interested to have you know
inputs into our redesign process for a
new version of OpenCog but but also
we're doing a lot of very interesting
research I mean what we're working on on
data analysis for kovat clinical trials
we're working with Hanson robotics we're
doing a lot of cool things with the
current version of of OpenCog now so
that there's certainly opportunity to
jump into OpenCog or various other open
source API oriented projects so would
you say there's like masters and PhD
thesis is in there plenty yeah plenty of
course I mean the challenge is to find a
supervisor who wants to foster that sort
of research but it's way easier than it
was when I got my PhD sure
you